eh oh so it's an anime rap challenge huh
shout out to boot talks anime for
bringing this back but you know I had to
switch to beat up a little bit
shout out to the whole rant cafe crew
anime cypher 2017 Anna Mac let's go
anime uproar the rain no stopping us so
I spent his lyrics in the spirit of
coming a bro I'm Way above you so y'all
just watching the throne being fair
outdoor [ __ ] what you watching
me from your girl you know she call me
senpai when I walk in the door I tell a
beat it but she didn't she just love me
some more why just record I can record
setting records what did you bro says in
two hours I say in 20 seconds you can't
reach the level that I say on I'm
watching cage or what these dudes is
watching K on man I would love to see
the drug that [ __ ] a day on if they
think they couldn't even smell the court
of play on a y'all gotta switch the flow
up for a second got a switch and slow up
for a second yo yo yo yo yo check your
knowledge make Tauzin to like look like
lost paws and if you want to battle with
me it's a lost cause when your woman
holla at me and the lines cross i'ma
call you and a billion for my lost
drawers it's Anna Mac baby
they say I'm mad crazy cuz I'm really
mad lately but the game is wack lately
so I make these suckers face it you
cannot learn about the world from your
mother's face man I'm the [ __ ]
greatest maybe you can learn a lesson
heyo cyanide how's this for a first
impression
[Music]
big thank you to my apart a give me on
Twitter and now I tag everybody on rant
cafe every single person that ever
appeared on rancor face you're tagged
right now also Knox talking bro you're
tagged Ranke paid 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
every Thursday come at me bro
[Music]